[Music]
this new show you have House of Lies
getting a lot of attention first of all
the opening scene of the very first show
really grabs your attention a lot of Don
Cheadle in that opening show you see all
of Don Cheadle a lot more of Don Cheadle
than maybe some people want to see we're
speaking in riddles now you are naked
yeah but as we're completely naked in
the opening of the show and I've watched
it many times but it's funny because
this character you're playing is quite
he's ruthless he's not politically
correct no he will he'll sink to the
lowest level to get what he wants and I
was curious people might who know you
might think hey I'm seeing a different
Don Cheadle here than the Don Cheadle I
know right is that true - your friends
think look at this show and look at this
character and think I don't know this
Don Cheadle know my friends and family
know that to be who I really am Wow yeah
that's the bastard I grew up with yeah
no only you get to revel in my reality
now a lot of actors when they're
struggling they are waiters for a while
and I you know they just go and they
they get a job as a waiter and a lot of
the people here in LA a lot of people in
New York if you stop and talk to them
and they're waiting on you in a
restaurant they're actors you actually
went to waiter school and I didn't know
that people did that is that right I did
it I did it the proper way if you're
gonna be a waiter
go - waiter school I didn't even know
there really was waiter school I don't
think there is any more grand opening
grand closing no yeah there was a school
out here was right on Sunset and like
Martell I think it was a professional
waiter school an idea was you go to the
school you learn how to do it the right
way right and then when you graduate the
guy who ran the school had all the best
tips - all you know well here's my Spago
contact you call them and you'll get in
there and there's no ivy by the shore
you go by there they'll hook you up so I
graduated from that and I was looking to
go get a good choice job as a waiter and
then I got a job and I never never had
to do it now is it now so you know the
the real what it takes to be a good
waiter yeah does this make you maybe
critical when someone's waiting on you
in a restaurant and even noticing what
they're doing if they don't do something
correctly hyper hyper critical right yes
and that must be fun yes no I mean I've
let it go by now I've since had a new
career so I have to grind on waiters so
hard yeah but yeah don't you give them a
hard time for like well I would notice
if you know you reach across me you know
it's like no come on you're not supposed
to reach across this way don't you go to
professional waiters tell them dancing
yeah I'm their only graduate don't know
hey that's good